j'ai envie de dire à delphine temps
bienvenue dans le monde des grands mais
heureusement plus réellement par vingt
trente mille euros mais quand il est
vain alors si la droite je chéris c'est
la vie ça tu es de leur poule et ses
hommes sont présents jeux de leur mort
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
5 millions de vues pour valider au pape
le dire sinon
[Applaudissements]
ranque aurait tourné 2 5 de la saison
une au cas où canal+ refusé que la série
se termine par la mort du héros tu
valides un faux pas vrai ou faux ouais
bah ouais c'était un peu risqué et puis
surtout c'est avec l'argent de carhaix
plus qu'on fait cette série quand même
donc il faut leur demander leur avis
parfois et donc j'ai tourné deux fin au
cas où ils trouvent ça trop dur et trop
risqué parce que quand une autre héros
ça veut dire que potentiellement on
n'était pas forcément capable de faire
d'autres saison sans lui et finalement
ils m'ont fait confiance la série de
fonds de lacaune est un remake baptisé
invalidée dans laquelle on suit les
aventures de bernard montiel
[Rires]
dans les acteurs phares deux séries à
brahim qui a eu des soucis à cause d'une
vidéo il il ya quelques temps tu n'as eu
tu ta de ses nouvelles ouais ouais je
fais partie de ceux qu'ils arrivent à
appeler
qu'est ce qu'on peut dire qu'ils en
prison au maroc pour une vidéo voilà
qu'il a fait et qui est ivre c'est une
mauvaise blague et je sais que ça fait
énormément de peine ce qui s'est passé
et que voilà oui parce que tous ceux qui
le connaissent savent que c'est un
gentil mec qui qui fait une blague
pourrie qui a fait une blague pourrie
qui a complètement conscience que cela a
blessé des gens parce que ça c'est
indéniable on le sait tous autour des
années dans la jungle ont été touchés ce
qu'on peut dire c'est que ce n'était pas
sa volonté est qu'aujourd'hui ben il le
paie il est en prison au maroc pour
cette parodie rapplique à début décembre
je crois
regardez c'est un jeune homme de 17 ans
qui a été violemment attaqué par une
dizaine de jeunes en pleine rue c'était
le 30 septembre dernier à montgeron dans
l'essonne regarde
ciani ciamel d'être avec nous ce soir
merci à vous merci merci à nice comment
ça a commencé en fait bah en fait
chanter avec ma meilleure amie des
pêcheries du coup il ya des dizaines des
mecs qui l'ont interpellé est d'abord
ils ont interpellé d'abord et louis
ouais tu crois ne s'est pas retourné moi
je sortais juste derrière ils m'ont
d'abord on se tait 2 pd2 gay g après
j'ai pris le bras de ma meilleure amie
on est avancé ils m'ont d'abord attrapé
par derrière ils m'ont jeté mon fera t g
combat mais rania s'interpose et âme à
relever on a avancé notre chemin alors
là c'était de g et c'était venus des
deux côtés du bâtiment ils m'ont alors
primes ont connu matin contre le
grillage m'ont jeté par terre ou en
frapper ou des coups de poing des chutes
dans la tête qu'est ce que tu t'es dit à
ce moment là que j'allais mourir
ce kit ont parlé après l'agression le
monde c'était bien marché par marché
pondent un [ __ ]
satan n'a pas parlé non ces deux
commissariats cavac ma mère pour des
guillemets parce que s'il répétait cette
vidéo mais n'aura pas eu tout ça en fait
j'aurais rien du tout à l'heure tu
disais que ta vie était timide et foot
us je ne peux pas entendre ça d'un
garçon
comme toi qui a tout pour toi ce que tu
es team je voyais tout à l'heure tu es
un très beau garçon tu t'exprimes très
bien la 17e à la vie devant toi on peut
pas entendre ça comprenez moi que se
faire frapper tout le temps c'est
parfait mais plus le temps c'est plus
une vie je passe ma télé ou quotidien
fait mais tu pattes non mais c'est pas
fini du tout au contraire
en tout cas nous on souhaite beaucoup de
bonheur pour yanis on sera là pour toi
on va t'aider
ce drame est ce que c'est un drame c'est
peut-être le tournant tu t'habilles
aussi et ce peut-être que ce drame peut
faire réagir
et j'en ai peut-être que ça va faire que
ta vie va s'améliorer aussi à partir de
maintenant bizarrement
est ce que tu dis aux gens qui disent
eric zemmour il nous fait peur bah je
leur dis qu'il faut pas en avoir peur en
fait on est en france on est dans un
pays qui est bien foutu les gens ils
sont page tarbes et aux dernières
nouvelles déjà je vais dire est qu'on
est très proche par exemple à ce qu'il
disait sur les lgbt à l'école madame
mais pense la même chose que moi
normalement si c'est une vraie musulmane
pratiquante
c'est un truc
qui veut voter pour eric zemmour parce
qu'il est cash parce qu'il a grandi dans
le 9 3
il dit des choses mais il les fera pas
avec lui avec 1,9 me sentirais plus en
sécurité en fait c'est sur du vide
concrètement que se base est apte à
conviction que là tu fais du che
répliqué en train de choisir des
morceaux de ce que non non non non c'est
priscilla daily mail mot pour mot ce que
tu as dit non non je suis pas du tout
malhonnête sur ça et moi parce que je
comprends pas c'est pour ça ça t'évoque
quoi un musulman qui votent pour eric
zemmour non en fait c'est franchement je
suis désolé a voté pour mais non c'est
ouais pour moi c'est incompatible mais
c'est même pas ça qui m'inquiète c'est
qu'en fait il a même pas de raisonnement
si en face de moi j'avais un musulman
qui m'a apporté 3 arguments on aurait pu
discuter mais franchement il n'y a aucun
qui me convainc alors tout ira bien
voulu mais c'est comme ça que je mets ça
marche pas c'est évident
toi tu me réduit à ma religion parce que
tu as commencé par là et ben moi je
pense aux valeurs françaises à
commencer par ça t'as vu ta tu as vu en
moi un voile est une femme musulmane
c'est tout ce que tu as vu mes chaînes
françaises et j'ai un cerveau n'en
déplaise à certains une action pas
encore apte à carson à leur tête mais je
suis française et je réfléchis avec les
valeurs françaises mais c'est plus de
valeur qu'un chef pauvreté etc avec
pardon mais jamais puisque bref s'il en
reste a dit fier en m'expliquant que
parce que je porte un voile je veux pas
défendre les femmes et c'est justement
parce que je le porte et que je défends
la liberté pour tous de se vêtir comme
il le souhaite les français les français
me croit les bruins ne croient plus que
vous comme ça fait des mois que vous
êtes château visite des choses
franchement qui nous dit vous dites des
choses vous vous répétez d'être un
disque rayé vous êtes les zemmour de
wisches mais vraiment
[Applaudissements]
vendredi soir l'ex miss france delphine
wespiser déclaré avoir été victime d'une
agression je viens de me faire agresser
dans la rue en un tour de passe passe ma
montre a disparu si on peut déplorer ce
genre d'acte la deuxième partie de son
message a suscité de nombreuses
réactions
marre de ce pays que fait la police
notamment celle du syndicat policier
alliance du grand est qui a tenu à lui
répondre à travers un communiqué d'abord
en déclarant cette polémique de stériles
alors date donc derrière après
mais du coup sûr un star je sais même
pas comment faire en fait j'appelle même
pas le 17 le premier truc que je fais je
vais avec mes potes et je fais le tour
de mulhouse pour voir si je retrouve
cette personne parce que voilà j'ai pas
le réfléchir jamais l'écriture je viens
de me faire agresser dans la rue en un
tour de passe passe ma montre a disparu
marre de ce pays que fait la police nous
avons tourné une heure pour retrouver
mon agresseur et nous n'avons pas vu une
seule patrouille de police pendant tout
ce temps donc là là c'est vrai que c'est
ça qui a fait énormément rire aussi et
au final j'appelle pas du tout le 17
j'appelle deux personnes que je connais
qui sont la police je leur écris sur
messenger et je le redis je me suis fait
voler ma montre qu'est ce que je fais ce
que j'attends d'un 10 pour porter
plainte ils m'ont dit maintenant mais
delphine le premier truc tu appelles le
17 oui tout de suite tout de suite mais
bon moi je le savais pas je te au final
à saint-dié l'histoire c'est une demande
que fait la police sans l'avoir appelée
oui je suis celle qui c'est pour ça mais
je n'ai pas l'habitude en fait ce sont
les maires de la province pour soi dès
que fait la police parce qu'elle était
allée et à la tournée avec ses potes
belga gl a pas vu une patrouille de la
police à tourner 24 dans ta rue
pour dire à delphine bienvenue dans le
monde des grands
dans le grand monde à plus de 20000 ou
trente mille ou 40 ans je ne sais pas
j'en sais rien 10000 euros s'ils lui ont
volé ce n'est pas pour la revendre 5
euros cinq ans ils ont volé c'est qu'ils
savaient pourquoi ils vont voler ils ont
vu descendre du train et il ya des codes
c'est con à dire mais à des codes quand
tu dis dans le métro tout le monde en
rêve c'est maintenant les gens dans le
métro on lève pas leur nom gare de
remonter on leur vole pas leur montre si
son parti cible et delphine parce qu'il
savait très bien que derrière il a
revanche elles montrent que tu tu
achèteras quand tu rembourses sera
celle-là enlève malheureusement c'est il
est horrible
c'est la vie elle monte à 20 30 millions
les vins
cérisola vises un tu es de leur
s'est rendu compte qu'on disait des
femmes attention mettez pas les jupes
les filles
tu mets marre de ce pays mamane avons
malheureusement il ya des amis des
proches de marine le pen d'eric zemmour
qui ont twitté qui ont repris cette
affaire pour en faire de la récupération
politique c'est à dire qu'on prend un
fait divers et on fait de la politique
la politique avec sa
sécurité oui il peut y avoir des faits
divers là je trouve ça gênant c'est un
cas qui peut être isolé et faut pas en
faire des généralités parce qu'après il
peut faire des amalgames
vous avez quel âge à l'époque j'avais 22
ans et l'huile en avaient ils allaient
revoir car il avait 13 ans 13 ans ff14
l'aviez-vous non tous les deux vous
aviez une vie intime oui d'ubs à la
suite de ça je suis tombée enceinte de
lui et je suis parti sans lui donner
d'explications alors c'est vrai que sa
rousseur rougerie est ce que vous
comprenez que ça fasse scandale lié aux
tendons oui ah ben moi c'est écrit me
met extrêmement mal à l'aise déjà c'est
pas parce que ça existe qu'il faut le
mettre en avant dans une émission de
témoignages c'est pas non plus une
émission d'information
et puis ensuite ce qui m'agace c'est que
le ton de l'interview est
particulièrement bienveillants parce que
c'est une femme j'aurais bien voulu voir
ce que ça aurait donné ça a été un homme
1 204 et geignant france est une fille
de 13 ans tous deux restent un pédophile
à la vérité il ya plein de deux d'ados
qui font leur première fois 13 ans il
suffit d'un accident sur la première
fois 13 ans pour que la personne en face
effectivement ton
il a 13 ans donc et voilà que les gens
qui font ça vous choque pas non non ça
ne me choque pas non mais mathieu en
fait je donne pas ton avis vu que je
donne mon rôle
avants 16 ans j'étais avec quelqu'un
j'ai commencé d'ailleurs à 13 ans et
c'est une relation très sérieuse avec
qui je restais pendant neuf ans problème
qui était maltraitée minaj et non on
avait le même match
change tout
delphine pardonne moi un garçon pourquoi
pas précoce c'est l'amour avec une jeune
fille elle aussi précoce mais ils ont le
même âge c'est pas la même problématique
là ce qui pose question la loi c'est
qu'on a une gêne à une personne qui est
majeure au dessus de la de la majorité
avec quelqu'un qui est en dessous y
compris de la majorité sexuelle et
genres une différence d'âge après la
grille d'accords avec mathieu elle est
hors la loi parce qu'à 13 ans il ya
c'est un détournement de mineur et donc
c'est très grave après c'est le co le
côté je suis tombée enceinte où ça veut
dire qu'elle sait pas protégés c'est à
dire qu'à pas de pilule ça veut dire
qu'à pas de préservatif donc on tombe
enceinte comme ça bon ben c'est pas
grave après tout on tombe enceinte
comment va dans un magasin où on va au
fast food et puis après on se tire parce
que bon après tout c'est pas grave on
part donc on fait un enfant comme ça
puis après on aille à plus de pères
fondateurs d'irresponsabilité
aujourd'hui on fait des enfants comme ça
comme ça je trouve que c'est super grave
les images diffusées sur les réseaux
sociaux on peut apercevoir un élève qui
tentent de quitter la classe avant de
projeter violemment son enseignante au
sol
vidéo qui a provoqué une nouvelle vague
d'indignation et tu remets en question
l'autorité de l'éducation nationale dans
les quartiers sensibles moi quand j'ai
vu tomber la preuve c'est la république
que j'ai vu tomber des mini des rouges
tracées du maire de la ville m c'est un
élève dissipé énoncé par neil est
dissipée c'est un élève dissipé c'est un
autre qui filme la scène et qui en plus
la poste sur les réseaux et toute une
classe 10 marais qui se fait rien donc
pour moi c'est pas un élève qu'il faut
sanctionner ces au moins plusieurs
élèves voire toute la classe
bien sûr que non et même à la personne
qui a filmé heureusement qu'elle a filmé
que l'on voit un peu leur espace dans
l'es4
cette mamie pour des populations de ces
lointains paris pour dénoncer pas du
tout mais si mais si autrement non pas
la république j'avais un très important
que l'on voit ce qui peut arriver à
l'ats eric est avec le secrétaire d'état
chargé de la jeunesse et de l'engagement
quand vous voyez ça c'est inadmissible
c'est inadmissible de et c'est pas
justifiable mais croit ces graphes et en
fait ce qui est grave c'est que ce
garçon déjà y est hyper violent fait
tomber la preuve c'est une chose il ne
respecte pas son autorité parce que lui
dit s'asseoir il n'a pas l'air de
franchement de l'écouté et 2 celui qui
filme c'est grave oui en fait c'est
faire si grave est-ce qu'on est
interdite dans les collèges et dans les
initiés les téléphones portables pour
éviter ça et on peut s'y fait part que
filmer il filme et publie et publiant
vraiment en mode diffusion c'est un truc
qui se passe regardez ce qui se confirme
c'est hyper grave il faut
responsabiliser les parents mais pas
quand le gamin il a 15 16 ans avant moi
à 15 16 ans j'étais foutu jeu vidé des
extincteurs au collège j'étais
travailler à 15 ans j'étais mort à 15 c
au cp ce1 cm1 c'est là qu'il faut déjà
dire aux enfants ont fait pas et aux
parents on ne fait pas n'importe quoi
avec l'école de la république on on
vient pour apprendre les seuls gens qui
peuvent te sauver ces mecs là excès les
profs personnes les aides ni dans le
quartier sont pas aidés ni leurs parents
ils sont pas aidés parce que leurs
parents ils ont aussi des problèmes les
seuls gens qui peuvent te donner du
savoir est mon plus gros regret de ma
vie c'est d'avoir insulté des profs
c'est d'avoir craché dans une classe et
d'avoir vidé des extincteurs dans deux
sas aujourd'hui à 45 ans c'est mon plus
gros regret
moi je vous dis honnêtement il dit
j'aurais pu aller dans la rue mais il ya
des gens qui sont dans la rue il ya des
gens qui n'ont rien il ya des gens qui
ont été brisés par la crise sanitaire il
ya des gens qui aujourd'hui n'ont pas à
manger et lui joue avec ça on dit
moi je trouve que c'est une façon
s'escrimer comme une autre il faut
toujours s'arrêter sur les mollets c'est
une expression c'est une phrase il il
existe il explique juste qu'il a peur du
futur et c'est tout à son honneur c'est
que c'est quelqu'un qui est passé avec
angoisse et orientations
en quoi vous n'êtes pas en quoi c'est
vous moi devriez
c'est pas des métiers ordinaire c'est
moi je dis ici que c'est pas un métier
c'est vrai que c'est une récré
il va sur scène il sur scène longtemps
mais c'est du travail dhabi si
la démarche qui me dérange le plus c'est
vite fuyons tf1 lui a donné sa chance là
c'est dégueulasse qui rend je vais dire
que ça va tu vas trouver en corse et
s'accroche pas tu vas trois ans comme
l'une des deux dates ci fait là tf1 lui
donne sa chance dès qu'ils voient que le
vent y tourne à balocco vite j'ai fait
me retourne à la retrouve à la rue comme
de tas de français qui sont vraiment à
la rue pour devrait lui qu'est ce qu'il
a fait c'est barrett chez tf1 en disant
c'est france 2
qui chez france 2 c'est le pognon des
français qui payent des impôts
partie le cas lyonnais il est parti
comme un mercenaire chercher la sécurité
chez france télévision je sais le rythme
a baissé que ça et tu peux pas sortir
une wii maladroite même consenti ville
de dire aux gens j'ai peur de me
retrouver sans rien du jour la main si
tu as peur va chercher un cdi quelque
part va chercher un cd ça fait 28 ans
que jean cerner d'accord on va pas
manquer si tu veux venir livrer tu sera
pas sans lendemain elle n'aurait pas m
koné tranquille
cette phrase là tu la sors à chaque
émission est dans le tunnel j'aurais
mais c'est quoi un rapport shaq fu fait
ce que sais tu sais ce qui s'est passé
tandis que tu connaissais vie ce qui
s'est passé en haute altitude et
novatrice et penser en terme de
comportement que ce mec qui s'est passé
en charente au nom de quoi tu me dénonce
arrête je dénonce pas jeudi que ses
propos sont en train de donner son avis
est en train de me parler de minos
encore une phrase en sort une phrase de
semaine c'est pas n'importe quoi c'est
juste que vous avez peur toi la première
comptez pas sur la table il pourquoi je
suis pas fort
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]